[Musique]
paris tout est magie la la la la la
aj magie
[Musique]
merlin chanteur est joli match en terre
gelée rouler une pelle puis le faire un
bisou bonjour merlet le chanteur tué le
10 minutes
oui nate et mimoun chent de présenter
mon fidèle assistant avant ce soir
zizou l'assistante merlin l'enchanteur
assises ou que je lis ou je vais faire
un bisou bonjour le ciseau
la dig oui tu la princesse qui embrasse
oui là des mimiques oui oh quel plaisir
de rencontrer une âme charitable pour te
récompense et je vais te changer ta
petite trombi ça si sochaux détient pro
celle là abracadabra corps nous en
cul-de-poule boum tchak
monsieur t'es trompé dans la formule de
la recommencer
c'est tout cornes de bouc préservatif en
bois bourbon qu'elle était déjà la
formule préservatif en bois le
préservatif en boire
c'est comme ça je suis la porte pitié
salut les cartes vermeil vous avez pas
vu par hasard
naji mook mois promise 4 le prince le
bonnet ou arrangé les choses
le prince lui à les retrouver je la
tiens jacques un préservatif hautbois
cor n'occulte boum tchak oman altino
fois ma beauté
[Musique]